and now for a special Thanksgiving treat
the moving conclusion my exclusive
interview with Academy award-winning
actor Jon Voight from his surprising
first role on Broadway to his Golden
Globe winning performance on TVs ray
Donovan take a look at this now I was
surprised to learn that in 1961 Jon
Voight was in the original production of
sound of music as Roth I filled in I was
the first replacement after two years I
got to work two weeks with Mary Martin
Mary Martin was fantastic I assumed that
she after two years that she was just
you know phoning it in and just she
wasn't she was a great listener it's
just the you know she she really when I
was on stage with it she was listening
to me she was responding to me the night
I was quite surprised and the first note
I got after I had an opening night
performance my first performance and I
was very good in that performance you
know the energy was high and I was the
adrenaline was working and I gave a
pretty good performance and I just got
one note he said don't upstage miss
Martin in 1978 you go on to win an Oscar
for coming home which really captured
the Vietnam that a gung-ho marine who
finds himself paralyzed what changed in
you as a man after playing that role did
it sensitize you to the plight of
veterans coming back from Vietnam it did
indeed I was turning at that time from
being a liberal to being
more conservative but I hadn't made the
full transition I was very shocked when
we pulled out of Vietnam was the
slaughter the Communists delivered to
Cambodia Laos and Vietnam the left just
celebrated that as a victory
and I'm thinking what was that right and
you're not paying any attention to all
of this horror that was created we are
pulling out that was the state I was in
was making the film and I spent a lot of
time in a place called Rancho Los Amigos
which no longer exists as the spinal
cord injury place but but I went down
there and spent the nights and some of
the rooms and heard the voices and some
of the moans and stuff of the people who
were who had these injuries their
suffering was what I was supposed to
portray and so I was Wed to them and I
was trying to be right to get this right
for these guys
you did yeah no you got it I just had
this accident with the helicopter in
Afghanistan and the president took you
out to Dover to receive the bodies of
these soldiers right he felt that I had
empathy for the families and invited me
see would you like to come I said yeah
yes it would I'd like to see that
ceremony performed and say my prayers
and and salute those caskets the
ceremony was so it's interesting about
form let's say art there's an art to it
right I was so grateful to be there you
know it was it this it's an incredible
thing to witness it's a ritual and it
and that and that ritual that art made
the statement of our respect and our
gratitude for the sacrifices of our
military and I'm sure it was the dignity
of it was effecting to that sending line
no sandwich you played everything from
john paul ii FDR is the president
referenced the other day Howard Cosell
and now this ex-con Mickey Donovan who
has become sort of the star of Ray
Donovan I know where ray is the star but
you really was Daria but this this role
he sly he's dangerous where does this
come from John you know it is a cover-up
it's somebody wrote this terrible
character I and a body it we
occasionally you go to these Emmy events
where they interact with many people and
they asked me how do you come to this
role and I say well I do this and I do
this I talked about the the work I did
as a boxer so I'm you know always
physicality we're walking dogs and then
I just go out they say actually I go out
and I myself what's John Voight's legacy
I'd like to disappear from Jon Voight
and just a source of
truth from above instead of just as you
know an actor but I have a great love
for my my past my dad my family and the
people that I've been fortunate to be
associated with during my career
so I can't wipe that away through your
work you are a source of truthfulness uh
thank you for being with us well that
was just a piece of our interview with
Jon Voight for the full package go to
fox nation dot-com click on Laura and
Raymond they have free trial membership
so you got nothing to lose go enjoy
yourself Fox nation.com